feels good to be back here it does happy
five year anniversary dude yeah
we can actually
yeah it feels good man yeah it does
um back in the old apartment
this is way better yes it's way better
we should fire everywhere we [ __ ] up
big time we didn't the spaceship and all
we were just thinking too big we didn't
need all that no
no you're gonna see Candace on stockx
pretty soon
yeah dude not for much either oh it's 50
bucks she's yours dude
with the employees yeah with the staff
you can have Ryan yeah Luke everybody
um they didn't even know we're talking
[ __ ] because they're not here yeah it's
great it's just us we could talk about
how weird Ryan's head shape is
[Music]
it's a little bit weird pretty weird
yeah yeah it's odd yeah it is odd yeah I
don't like it no
well your sister in the since we're in
the old apartment
this feels good doesn't it yeah doesn't
it isn't it weird it is weird what did
you get how to get some great white you
know oh no way really
no not really I had to pick up from
somewhere else
it is a breakfast burrito just like how
we used to and this is from great white
or is this from somewhere else it's from
somewhere else I think that's better
okay but we can pretend got it all right
so we're gonna we're gonna eat on the
mic yeah this is how we're gonna
celebrate five years oh yeah is by
eating on the mic dude mad casual yeah
it has to be okay this is great this is
this is really great I missed you I miss
you too bro being right here
damn with the with the pineapple
I know we got the little shelf thing
here I believe she stayed there the
whole time I know what's her name well
I've just I've just continued
renting this apartment yeah just in case
we've ever wanted to do this Bring It
Back to Basics I've just continued this
has been you know five years now people
don't realize that's why you've been
doing all these brand deals yeah it's
just gonna preserves are expensive yeah
yeah rent's gone up on this [ __ ]
yeah it turns out it's not economical to
rent an apartment that you're not using
or subleasing or anything just been
empty do you remember the cost of this
apartment yeah it was when you first
started it was
um it was something brutal I thought
I think it was eight thousand dollars
I'm no yeah I think it was twenty
thousand dollars now I remember I was
paying I think I was paying
eighteen hundred bucks a month because I
got the best room yeah
the one with the little balcony on it
yeah you did have the best room so it's
probably close to like probably like
just over four thousand for a three
bedroom that's
for that time
that was crazy but what do you think
what do you think this is now it's like
probably 6K yeah probably
gone crazy yeah dude I gotta take a bite
I know me too I'm starving
it's really weird how just going to
these microphones
it puts me right back to what the good
old days yeah just five times simpler
times much simpler times
I was thinking
because that was my first episode I
missed that was like emotionally very
hard for me was it to miss an episode
yeah I'm like damn but then I thought
about it I'm like I should have called
out more yeah you were having way more
fun yeah you just going to Europe just
doing things I'm like why didn't I do
that it's not that bad yeah that's true
you didn't wake up on Tuesday and go oh
ah wait today's it oh wait I don't have
to do [ __ ] no I've never
because you know I'm such a I'm such a
freak
I couldn't I couldn't leave it alone you
go and then I go I can you know I'll
give I'll give you a chew time
and then I'll get some chew time
you'll be done faster though although I
have to say I I've picked up my eating
speed
in recent months I'm starting to get the
things that you get when you house
something
and then your stomach hurts and the
chest the chest [ __ ] is so scary yes
dude I used
we were talking about this recently
weren't we yeah we
I used to
um the first time I actually got that I
was high as hell I thought it was dying
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] scary no I don't
know why but it like runs in my family
yeah so my dad gets this
and now I get it it's like when you eat
I don't know what it is but when you eat
too fast it all gets stuck right here
and then it feels like you're like
choking and suffocating and drowning at
the same time
and you make this weird like yeah oh
this is horrible like burp slash gag
slash like just last last gasp for air
before you die and your ladies looking
at you like what's wrong you're like
stuck yeah come on you're like water
yeah but that doesn't help no because
the water just stacks on top yeah and
then you got more [ __ ] up to here
yeah it happened to me and then finally
everything goes and it all falls down at
one time and you're like oh thank
[ __ ] God
I live to see another day and then you
with all the food and you're back at it
again it happens again you know a minute
later
she's like you know you don't have to
just eat just pace yourself yeah that's
what who's pacing themselves I know like
like just this sitting here right now is
stressing me out so like what if a dog
jumps up and eats this like it's just
it's just yeah exactly don't do that
I don't want to eat this I just Reach
For It guys we can take little nibbles
no let me say this I've been thinking a
lot you know coming in this episode in
the past 24 hours you know then versus
now and I think that's a thing that's
definitely changed for me I think it
used to be such a
uh a soulless person what happened
oh that I'm listening now you remember
uh a stock [ __ ] I got Foods whatever
Foods whatever I think in the last year
or two I've come around on food I think
I'm more on more your side of the
spectrum now where I'm like damn like I
really want to eat this also better than
great white right
yeah I don't know actually what's your
okay you like that burrito a lot do you
yeah I always thought it was too wet
no I like it all right what's the best
one
was the best one in La breakfast burrito
[ __ ]
I'm not red kopax no I'm not gonna
pretend I'm a massive connoisseur of um
breakfast burritos you like them though
I do but I just tend to eat at home
like you make them no no like oh [ __ ] I
feel like every time you order food here
it's a breakfast burrito yeah oh okay
all right
what I've been getting here at your
apartment is um I've been ordering
Hilltop oh yeah yeah that's a good one
yeah Hilltop is is amazing
um this is all right you know it's a
good um I like that they Grill it I like
that's a little bit yeah a little bit
drier
but what you said Colfax Colfax is good
that's like the one that you know
infatuation and everyone says is the
number one one but I think Lily's in
Malibu is my favorite well either that
or flake still
that's what we used to get that's what
we should have gone right yeah I haven't
had flaking yeah yeah yeah yeah damn
yeah I used to go there like every
weekend
Studio [ __ ] up by letting us do this
why but it's over what we're selling the
studio
this is way better
it is it's easier to have
like little [ __ ] conversations like
that yeah
I feel like if we were on Candace
talking about breakfast because we're
like shut up yeah we would there's
there's way more pressure with all that
gear there is there's lights and it's
like we gotta this is so funny we have
to talk about animal death yeah you know
but here it's a bit more tempered
subdued
yeah Ryan you guys are all fired
well because we're not here so oh yeah
we could just say they're gonna hear
that in post I know but we're not even
gonna edit this actually yeah this is
like old days yeah wind up the audio put
it out Pump Pump It
oh and if you guys thought you were
gonna see our faces for the last 20
minutes
nah now you're getting the title card
just like the old days we're doing it
exactly the [ __ ] same